[Music
] I'm just standing still for a while
What are you doing, but if you make a
mistake in the size and get stuck in your throat,
it's okay if it's crunchy and smaller than that.
Considering this time, today
I can do even such a small child with only radish.
Standing at me
[Music] I can't think
of the future
[Music] I
wonder if Ohara has decreased.
It will take, after
all, do you do this today?
Wait a minute, so it's almost empty, so I
managed to get to this point, and after I got to this point, I assembled it until it became soft.
It ’s good to get it properly and it ’s cold.
After all, I ’m gonna eat the rice I made
.
But it's
sweet
[music]
Somehow,
this kind of dining table
might be pretty good